les trottinettes en libre service
on en parle dans les médias et les
journalistes les plus téméraires en font
même la démonstration en direct à la
télé trottinette électrique c'est
formidable a classé dans le rayon
peut-être bonnes résolutions
les adeptes après si simple à utiliser
et efficace pour les courtes distances
et pour mousser le produit est bien les
fournisseurs font appel à d'immenses
vedettes comme usain bolt qui ici fait
la promotion d'une nouvelle trottinette
électrique à paris mais généralement
après un temps ça se garde de san
francisco à paris les citadelles se
plaignent de ce qui slalome sur les
trottoirs ou des trottinettes qui
traînent un peu partout pour en avoir vu
à traverser les feux ou d'essayer aucun
respect du code de la route et même pour
eux c'est extrêmement jeu en france le
comédien vincent lindon jeu y est allé
d'une charge un front de près à la télé
une trottinette ou roulent très vite
généralement de préférence avec un
enfant de trois ou quatre enquêteurs
tapons à l'école boulevard sébastopol à
25 à l'heure entre deux bus et voici que
les trottinettes électriques
débarqueront à montréal québec vient
d'autoriser cet été la tenue d'un projet
pilote dans la métropole
c'est un mode de mobilité intéressant
mais le responsable de la mobilité à la
ville veut éviter ici les erreurs
commises ailleurs on veut que la le
travail de s'assurer que le déploiement
se fasse bien ordonnée soit la
responsabilité des fournisseurs
c'est un privilège qu'on leur offre la
responsabilité c'est de s'assurer que ça
vienne pas encombrer le domaine public
le règlement adopté par la ville est
très clair on ne pourra pas laisser les
trottinettes électriques n'importe où
on pourra par exemple les stationner
contre un support à vélo et ce dans tous
les arrondissements de la ville au
centre ville on pourra stationner un
maximum de 4 contre les trottoirs dans
ces zones de dégagement cinq maires qui
a souvent au coin des rues
par la suite la ville va désigner deux
nouvelles zones de stationnement tout
aidant ou des laisses ton pour ne pas
générer de nuisances et si une
trottinette train sur le trottoir par
exemple eh bien c'est à l'opérateur de
la flotte que revient la responsabilité
de régler le problème
si la ville
ramasse une trottinette qui traîne de
ses l'entreprise qui fournit un service
qui va être mis à la mangue dans notre
règlement on s'assure que chaque
véhicule soit identifié avec un numéro
de téléphone une adresse courriel de
sites web pour qu'on puisse signaler les
problèmes tous les citoyens vont pour
signaler des problèmes
la ville va pouvoir le faire les
fournisseurs devront régler les
problèmes sans se risquent de perdre
leur permis
les visiteurs au sommet movin on sur la
mobilité durable ont pu faire l'essai
des trottinettes en libre service line
l'entreprise qui est présente dans une
centaine de villes se dit fin prête à
faire son entrée à montréal et à
respecter le cadre réglementaire de la
métropole
on pense que c'est très bien fait puis à
ses 107 ans prépare pas vraiment
supporté le règlement tout ce qui manque
avant de voir les trottinettes arrivée
sur la route c'est le feu vert de québec
on attend encore les réglementations
provinciales car pour ce qui est des
règles quand on roule du port du casque
ou de l'âge minimum laisser le ministère
des transports du québec qui va les
établir pendant le projet pilote
ça c'est pour les trottinettes
électriques en libre service
maintenant pour les trottinettes
électriques personnel 7 on peut déjà
acheter en magasin
et bien dites vous que l'utilisation de
presque tous les modèles est interdite
autant dans la rue que sont les pistes
cyclables officiellement un seul modèle
de trottinettes électriques est autorisé
sur la voie publique au québec c'est la
djibi fabriqués à sherbrooke qui fait
l'objet d'un projet pilote mené par la
société d'assurance automobile du québec
et pour avoir le droit de rouler angie
be il faut avoir 18 ans portait un
casque et avoir sur soi la preuve qu'on
a suivi une formation des règles qui
pour l'instant ne sont pas vraiment
impliqué